let's start with them the material today
again I'd really like to make an
interactive you have questions just
raise your hand and we'll answer them
right away I won't take a lot of
questions and then answer them all back
we'll just go back and forth quickly so
the topic is we talked about strategic
thinking on Sunday using that for
strategic problem solving but I think
one of the things now we'd like to move
into is strategic thinking in the area
of scale up and sustaining and maybe one
thing that I can help bring to this
group we each have our own skills but
maybe one thing I can help bring to this
group is we read the literature all the
time so what do we know from the
evidence about what works in scaling up
so that's sort of what I'm trying to get
across so it's always good to say why do
we care about a topic you're talking
about and I think the reason we care
about scale up is very often we have got
an individual case study of very high
performance we have a hospital that's
doing really well we have grand Bassa
that's doing unbelievably or bo me we
have a particular doctor who thought up
some interesting thing in a county
somewhere and we are pretty we have some
evidence this is seems like it's really
working pretty well but a question is
well how do I replicate that you're in
the ministries and the huge health
service how do I actually make what
worked so well in that one place just
make it happen through more districts
more counties more people and have a
greater impact and that's what I'm
really defining a scale up even though
there are many many terms for that I
mean widespread take up so a lot of
people are doing the thing that seems to
be an effective innovation or an
effective practice so clear to everybody
what i mean by scale up okay so i want
to tell a story and i don't know how
many people will know this story but
scale up can be tremendously slow and
not just in low-income settings and not
just in healthcare but in high-income
settings and in lots of different
sectors so is a good story of scurvy
which the doctors in the room know what
scurvy is but it's yuck you don't want
scurvy okay so between the years
fourteen hundred and eighteen hundred it
really was
main threat to naval cook cruise with up
to more than half the men on long
voyages getting scurvy and suffering
terribly from this disease in 1601 there
was someone named captain Lancaster who
figured out that he would try to give
three tablespoons of lemon juice widely
available very cheap three tablespoons
of lemon lemon juice to some men and not
give it to other men it's like the first
controlled trial and what happened
scurvy ended up killing forty percent of
the men in the boats that never got any
of the three tablespoons of lemon juice
and it killed zero people in the boats
that actually got the lemon juice so
this was pretty good even though it
wasn't randomized and even though it was
pretty good thinking that she may be
lemon juice could be helpful here so
that was 16 01 can you imagine it wasn't
until 1747 until there was the first
randomized control trial of this so it
was a hundred and fifty years and people
were not routinely using lemon juice in
that 150 years it wasn't like oh well
everybody knows it so we don't need to
study it nobody was using a people are
dying of scurvy completely unnecessarily
then in 1477 teen 47 there was a
randomized control trial in the British
Navy that was wildly successful and
everyone said you know lemon juice is
the way to go it's cheap it's easy it
doesn't even taste that bad everybody
will take it we'll just do it that way
it's still until 1805 the British Navy
had did nothing between 1747 and 1805
about this so it was only in 1805 that
the British Navy passed the proclamation
to have fruits as part of the diet in
navy ships so it's a 50 year lag what
happened and then that was only in the
Navy of course there's a huge board of
trade all of the merchants and actually
that was not passed widely to actually
order and really recommend and
guidelines to have fruits or something
like lemon juice on all board of trade
boats all merchants that were part of
the board of trade that was not done
until 1865 so if you look at the first
aha moment in 1601 and then the final
what i would call scale up where
everybody was doing it there's two
hundred and sixty-five years the past as
a long time so we get frustrated
ourselves with our little G why can't
people learn to this lettin the other
but this is something that is human
nature and has been in our history so
now what I want to move to is talk a
little bit about first I want to give
you some definitions and then I want to
draw in the literature well what do we
know about moving from one idea to many
to a scale up so first scale up to
define I'm using it to mean widespread
use of existing practices technology and
idea so it's not discovery it's I've
already had the discovery now how do I
move it out into general practice and I
also wanted to talk about two other
terms the diffusion of innovations is a
very common topic written about and it
really refers to the rate at which new
ideas spread through cultures
geographies or populations and some
people will distinguish diffusion from
dissemination they'll say these are two
different things diffusion more from
biological cell biology where you have I
don't know cell biology so I'm getting
on thin ground here but what we mean by
this is the passive spread from what's a
high concentration to a low
concentration no one does anything it
just goes out through the membrane and
you have it the idea out to a where it
was previously low concentration
dissemination is actually the active
push somebody in the ministry somebody
in an academic environment a
practitioner says we're going to sell
this out we're going to market it we're
going to push it out not just simply
passive diffusion so those two words are
described and we're going to really talk
a fair amount about dissemination okay
so many of you I think dr. oz rot maybe
brought this up on Sunday many of you or
maybe it was Marple I can't remember
somebody brought this up of the shift
the pattern of scale up that's seen this
this pattern of chain
is actually documented from economists
in looking at general textile industries
and then moved into health care starting
in like the mid-40s were the first
studies that started to document this
sort of approach to a population
changing and not just in healthcare but
in other areas so it's almost like a
biological rhythm this is the way change
happens and if you look at the beginning
of change are the innovators or the
people who you know they innovated they
came up with a good idea they tried it
out they saw it was successful and then
the early adopters another 13.5 percent
or so of groups these are often the
opinion leaders the people are kind of
tricky and risky and they'll go out and
try something then the early majority
and finally this late majority which I
think varkala was saying this is really
where we ought to spend our time is
working on these late majority and then
laggards that actually are thought never
to take it's the word never thought to
take up a change and if you put all your
energy into getting the laggards to buy
it you spent a lot of time and they may
never change anyhow right so if you look
at the yellow curve that's kind of the
important curve because the yellow curve
is what percent scale-up is there over
time now on the yellow curve the x axis
is time and the important part of this
curve is first the beginning part an
awful lot is happening in the beginning
when you don't see it and that I think
Rolanda your story was a little bit like
this because you sent us slides and so
we did nothing and I thought well you
didn't do nothing I mean you have a more
qualified delegation for this problem
now your Minister agreed this was an
important problem you had external
people coming in and saying you know you
had some support that's sort of the
beginning you know the innovators have
been found so I think when we get
discouraged a lot of times we're in that
little track where we feel like
something's happening but nobody's seen
it and then this large scale up really
that huge acceleration is the getting of
this early and late majority and then
the tapering off just means basically
some people will never take it up and
might as well stop spending your time on
it because they'll never take it up so
the big question this S curve is what
it's called and this S curve
has been found as I said again and again
and again but for leaders of scale up
our real question is can we change the
shape of that curve like what would the
shape of that curve be if it was ideal
you were really successful in scale up
what would the shape of that curve be
yeah straight straight and then and
we're like way back there just it's time
zero everybody's got it right you hardly
even have to say it like cell phones
they just reached happened at least here
I mean you know one day nobody had a
black bear and then everybody had a
blackberry so um so you're kind of
looking how can I do that and in a
private market it's easier like
blackberries blackberries in the US okay
they're affordable they solve your
problem everybody wants one there's a
market there's someone who wants to push
it out they make a profit by pushing it
out you're happier because you get it
that's what capitalism is but that's not
what healthcare is we have a capitalist
market in health care in low-income
settings to be able to push anything out
we have to sort of figure out how do we
push it out when there isn't a profit to
be made or if the profit is a social
profit it's something that well people
are living but that's different that
doesn't often motivate sadly doesn't
actually motivate so what do we use when
we don't necessarily have a private
market in which will actually
automatically diffuse it sort of tells
us maybe in some of these health care
and public health areas we can't use
just diffusion ie it won't just
naturally spread out because it's in
everybody's best interest rather we need
dissemination tactics where there is
some kind of strategic push to things
because there's not an automatic it's
certainly people always say is this an
idea that has legs if you ever heard of
that means it'll walk on its own and
sometimes health care ideas aren't like
that because of various because of
thousands of reasons and it not being a
perfect market of any kind so from the
literature the academics in the world
who have thought about scale-up actually
separate out the waste scale up
in several different stages and even
without reading the words when you see a
whole page of stages to get from
awareness of the thing to finally having
impact you figure it's going to take
some time and I think that's another
thing that we often don't or more people
that we're all advocating with maybe our
ministers of finance don't kind of
recognize that actually scale-up has to
go through all this different stuff in
order to finally have everyone doing it
so it beginning at awareness or
discovery the aha moment the first time
you know wow I see three tablespoons of
lemon juice matter but then this huge
agenda setting and priority setting how
do I get it on the agenda that we have
to worry about maternal mortality and
what a huge story we had yesterday from
Liberia about how they had worked this
piece of the scale up early is get it on
the President's agenda that it's the
president of maternal you know health
women's issues a third piece and many of
you have talked about this after it's on
the agenda and priority setting often
there is sort of the research that
debate the evaluation the
decision-making is this a good idea is
it not a good idea the Ethiopian team
has talked about this a lot so it's been
on the agenda that we're going to do
that the country is going to do
improvement of hospital functioning and
there's been a few aha moments with some
really great successes and maybe they're
in the place here in some ways over
search of a decision making well where
is this really it was how's it going to
work and who's going to do what and is
it really working or isn't it working
and I guess what makes this complicated
is dr. Gabe rob might be on step three
and dr. tedros might be on step 8 I'm
just using you as an example but the
point is we do I got a whole team doing
scale up everybody could kind of feel in
a different place like it's already on
my agenda I'm already working on it but
it may not be on the agenda someone else
so I guess some of the trick is how do
you get people in the same place on this
kind of scale up the fourth areas the
adoption of the new idea that adoption
from an academic point of view actually
doesn't mean you're changing any
it means you decided you committed to
doing it you made the commitment yes
we're going to do it that means you've
adopted the idea and then usually before
implementation there's still another
step of adaptation so in bomi county
they're going to do it one way and grand
Bassa they're going to do it another way
Lofa they're going to pick another way
some kind of adaptation of that and
things can go wrong there too when you
adapt right hugely adaptation the sixth
step here actually implementing that's
where for from the academic point of
view you're actually changing behavior
and implementation and then you adapt
and then you implement more and you
adapt and that keeps going ultimately
impact so I'm curious as you look at
this list whether you relate to it at
all and whether this actually seems like
the path you're on or the path you've
seen happen with the kind of
interventions you've done and where you
think the biggest stopping point is
where the biggest difficulty is in
driving a scale up anybody got any
opinions on that first of all do you
relate to the list or not really you do
relate to the list okay that's good yeah
dr. get robbed very good new idea on our
own scale up I read something about
scallops the difference between Beijing
every scale up based on practices and
good practices and going to scale up bed
on research other us yes is a
significant difference yeah collapse
just copying with the spot or not yeah
yeah somebody has done there you just
copy yeah you don't know the reason why
so has problems of understanding if you
do the pari passu resect that I am
trying to say then you learn more yeah
that that's the difference I'm raising
all the time with you and
in the platform so the I'm not for
agonist scallop at all I believe in the
scallop and in fact if I'm Italy just
incidentally my country believed had a
strategy is called scallop strategy
everything yeah what we do from the
farmers from the health workers let's
scale it up this is a strategy it's a
national strategy but if you do research
together side by side with that then you
know the reasons why you succeeded or
why you do this axiom yep and then you
understand yeah so I'd like to address
this a really really important point so
one could do scale up because up sorry
you know how we are in the u.s. we just
what yeah yeah okay so you know uh was
it KP oh yeah are you okay go ahead I
know hit it one more time oh yeah good
oh it's the Reds got to be on yep okay
don't touch anything okay yeah you got
it okay you're asking about which is the
key moment I think there are different
key moments in trying to scale up my
strategy Oh a model I I would say that
the first one is getting the political
will so that the understanding that this
model that we're trying to scale up is
contributing so we need some evidence
yeah that the model is is better than
what you and Ray yeah yeah that's also
they did the importance of the issue
because trying to to install an issue
into the political agenda it depends on
many factors depends on who is in the
government what are their interests what
is important or what is the surrounding
noise that is happening around the issue
so that's a key moment but also a second
key moment is once we have the political
will
a we need I guess two for the adoption
of the new idea to instrumentalize what
we'd have done that is successful and so
because when you go to other officer or
if it is a decentralized level will you
go to another Regional Authority they
ask you how do i do is and how much does
this cost and we're going to get the
funds for that no so you need to have a
good answer for for these three
questions yeah so the first question is
you need to instrumentalize the
strategies that were successful second
thing is you need to know how much does
this cost because sometimes we have what
I call the Cinderella phenomenon I think
you know you all know about the story of
Cinderella no she had this big party but
then it sound 12 bells of the midnight
and then she had the pumpking on her
hands sometimes pilots sometimes pilot
mothers are like that it was an exit
strategy by somebody their place we
place a lot a lot of funds and
assistance and visits and supervision
when we are making the pilot but then we
ask public officers to make the same
thing with less resources yeah that's
what i call the Cinderella not so we say
them now it's your turn do it the same
but it's not the same because it's not
as if we have been working this from the
beginning with the public officer so
also in terms of instrumentalization
this is very important from my point of
yeah pray comment yeah I think that's a
very nice model am I see that sometime
we have the bottleneck between the
adoption nap titian the research results
have come out I've been disseminated all
right then it stands there how does it
turn into policy for which people then
start implementing we've got a lot of
research it does have been done the
universities actually they are solution
to most of our problems yet the other
shows how to translate that
we need an implementation to murphys
after the dissemination some team that
were carried a gander for it and that is
where I see the leadership aspect Kunsan
ability to push the idea true I measured
is not taking we'll see about that depth
at for implementing young yeah I think
Zach you please we need to look at it's
absolutely like a handoff time you know
you've got the policy and then they're
different people who are going to then
implement it so that handoff and how you
make a team over the handoff very tricky
and we always refer to that slippage
from sort of what you had in the policy
to really what you end up getting big
and I don't think there's any clear
answer on that but I think what you said
is very right on target of that's what
leadership is how do you make the full
length I just want to make a comment
about this issue where you get the
research evidence that dr. geber I
brought up and you brought up ral a
little bit um you know I think there are
two schools of thought on this one being
really from the biomedical research and
it may not be biomedical it might be
health economics it may be more social
science oriented but there's a research
study that's done and it sort of brought
it's more of a top-down approach let's
design a study will do something here
and we won't do it there and then we
will see which got better and that often
gets published and that's often become
sort of the research base from which one
might do it I think there is also the
sort of bottom-up inductive approach
known as positive deviance where you
have got a a group could be a community
could be a single facility that's
getting fabulous performance from a
research standpoint you look at really
both qualitative and quantitative
outcomes and you say now this is a
incredible case and study that inside
out so you can get to what are the
determinants of that and then that may
be more replicate able it's sort of i
think that's a very competitive airy
compelling way probably we need both i'm
in the best place you need both because
it gives you the most confidence you
have a single case and you have a larger
study that's giving you the research the
broad based research
thank you very much drive back on the
these phases of skill up linking that
with the past but the pattern of skill
up and even with the s-curve of scale up
I'm wondering in Lincoln that with his
physical skill up when it comes to
awareness and discovery I wanted where
should we focus practically and in terms
of the target for that way for the
awareness and then email agenda setting
and prior to setting which category of
individual should we target the
innovators all the other early adopters
are early majority where should be our
focus practically yeah in trying to
ensure that the yeah that one is created
and the agenda is set yeah there I could
tell you from a research point of view
what people have found is the focus this
is post innovation so the focus here
should be on the opinion leaders who are
maybe not necessarily aware of it but
they bring a lot of people with them and
those are usually the early adopters
their thirteen percent of a population
it is not a big group but they bring
with them like a leverage point the
early adopters and the late adopters the
late early majority in late majority so
those early adopters are sort of the key
people that have to be in one and two
and they should be opinion leaders so
they're in the formal and informal
settings follow but if you look at a
primitive society yeah I think you want
to have a lot of pinyon leaders at the
top yeah but I think in private
practical sense within the open early
yesterday there may be people who are
like us I mean within that group good
day so I
and there could be very much a nickel
resist this killer process yeah that's
the problem if you have your opinion
leaders formal and informal so they
could be formal in there at the top of
the pyramid but they could be very
informal too and be the bottom I mean
they may not have a lot of status
depending I guess what country you're in
it but they carry other people with them
if they happen to be laggards also that
they don't like the idea they're against
it i mean i don't know i'd go find
another thing to scale up ha i would
just say use your energies where you
have potential i honestly Angela there's
also a time for scaling up and and when
it's not yet time mm-hmm you you can
just hit your head that's a good point
against the stone issue you find all
your opinion leaders are no my dear yeah
yeah yeah Richmond I guess wanted to
mention that sometimes too you would
have expressed and even written down
indication that people are interested to
help scale it up and even among the
opinion leaders and yet what is needed
to deliver it it's not forthcoming yep
so every time you talk about it it's
something that we all agree on we want
to work on but what is needed to move
from point A to point B yeah doesn't
come this sort of tries to at arielle i
think was racing is that when you say
here's my idea you need both sides of
that you need and here the benefits and
by the way this is the kind of
commitment we're talking about it's this
amount of money it's this amount of new
job descriptions new laws passed it sort
of follow up I think that's absolutely
right you know everybody wants to
monitor the system and do a valuation of
the system but when you say well no data
costs lots of money to do i was asking
Amy this the upper day okay you want
everybody to be in these GHI plus
countries to be evaluating how they're
doing but did you pay for statisticians
did you pay for data analysts did you
pay for data collectors so in giving
both sides of the equation is critical
and
usually I think it's hard to do because
we want people to agree that will do
this it's frustrating yes dr. rozran I
just want to remark on scaling up I
think the most important thing is what
to scale up we say we scale up
successful practices or best practices
and we have to agree on what's the best
practice because everybody would say his
is a best practice or is his best idea
mm so you know there is now an
initiative to standardize best practice
to register them to accredit ism so that
resources can be invested in a
successful practice which is really
successful practice yeah otherwise
everybody would say his innovation is
best his practice is best he has to be
scaled up and so on and so on so some
some countries even have best practice
centers yeah the you register it the
credit eat and then it's appropriate to
me to invest on those practices that are
really successful and that are really
best based on certain standards this one
one idea the other thing is where do we
really start scaling up do we start as a
stage of ideas or do we scale up
practices in my opinion and the way we
do business back home yeah we scale up
doable workable practices which have
demonstrated which are which have been
established as producing really good
results so do is do we start scaling up
at the stage of ideas because we don't
know whether whether these ideas could
be really you know transformed into some
practice or do we really do we need to
invest at the stage of amino do we need
to scale up practices that have
demonstrated and establish themselves to
be you know to have good outcomes so I
think we need to to be clear on that hmm
that's interesting you take an
incremental approach where you have an
idea you
try it out if it looks ok then you scale
or do you just have the good idea and go
big right away yeah you know most people
in the research would say that
incremental approach is more successful
but there's a lot of reality out there
that tells you something different we
didn't have a little internet we had the
internet so you know I don't know but
you know I think most political analysts
would normally say the slow you go from
the practice you pilot and go forward
there was a comment right there I think
Johnny yeah yeah thanks I think
sometimes also the one of the stumbling
blocks is the quality of the information
that is being provided and how it
relates to existing information I mean I
think as a follow-up to what the last
speaker said we have a plethora of
interventions available if you take
interventions to reduce child mortality
for instance we have bed nets in place
we have immunizations we have so many
things so if you come up with a new
intervention which you claim more by the
evidence that you provide reduces
mortality by say twenty percent it
sounds great but how does it compare
with existing interventions in place
because more often than not there is no
new money so the second point becomes
very important the health service need
to reprioritize based on the quality of
evidence available you should I shift my
money from bed nets to this new
intervention or what and most of our
research that is generated does not do a
comparative analysis on what extra
benefits that is being provided so it
becomes their agenda setting and
priority setting a little difficult yeah
ultimately it affects scaling up of such
new interventions so we have to Train
health economists who can do
cost-effectiveness analysis yeah yeah
you just look Tommy we're gonna
I'm stuck on the first line Oh get off
it uh yeah and I think of the corporate
world that is involved in and with
greater and greater successes involved
in more and more research and
development and I look at the issues in
health care how to take care of the
elderly with a declining base of work is
with an increasing number of people over
the age of 85 65 and 70 or I look at the
issues of health care in Africa the
issues of health care in China where
they're going to be 800 million people
without sufficient care right now
they'll improve it but that means
they'll still be 500 million people
comparative to the 50 million in the
united states that still don't have
health care I wonder if every single
program shouldn't build in everyone from
your ministry of health to your
reasoning district people to your
supervisor every single program one
percent of its endeavors in focusing on
discovery of new ideas experimenting and
pong and piloting it's interesting good
thank you for the comment yeah one
question for you the the adoption of the
new idea assume that this new idea is
inspirational in the original idea and
of course this idea has not just
flickered from the mind but has been a
reflection of the outside world I mean
some practice has yeah brought it into
your mind and you have reflected on it
so is not that the critical stage in the
faces of this scale up adoption of an
idea of an idea was to understand it and
believe in it yeah not only understand
it right Anala but commit to it but yes
committee believe in it and that is that
is why you need your evidences yeah it
is not why you need an organized body of
thought
don't you think yeah no I totally agree
this is an absolutely critical place and
it is you often built by a body of
thought and a body of evidence and the
only issue things can still go wrong
because you could adopt but that's the
classes slippage to then actually
implementing can go wrong so I think
it's you know each step has its
challenges in each step has it's sort of
critical moments where things can fail
but it helps us understand why we don't
scale up so easily all the time because
actually it's a complex process it's not
a simple at all process in there a lot
of steps including that one where things
can stop uh oh yeah Jen I'm actually
stuck on the research that's because you
do research yes exactly but I think in
the United States at least the research
and evaluation part of this particular
timeline is actually where things get
stuck particularly if there's a division
of opinion are not really a lot of
political will to see changes be made it
seems like at least in the states if you
want to delay something the way to do
that is to call for another Commission
or commissioned a study or have no
research be done I think that happens
all over the world yeah so it's I'm glad
you brought that up i mean we sit in
this balance right where we want more
research but we want to be really fast
and get the answer quickly in that
course that's not how research goes so i
think the the weighing off of these
different things is just an expression
of your leadership it's an expression of
how you sort of feel and deal with what
your practices on each of these i wanted
to just take a moment to move us on to
something i'm not going to cover all
these slides but i'm happy to talk with
anybody afterwards about any of the
ideas and i also would recommend that
you read one of the papers it's at the
end in implementation science about the
use of positive deviance because i think
it's a useful paper in terms of scale up
and using our practices to copy
practices when that works and when it
doesn't but i wanted to put this model
up which is from that paper but also
tries to integrate some of the
literature we have in trying to think of
the myriad of factors
so we have to think about implanting a
scale up aside from those stages we went
through if we had to put create buckets
of things we have to worry about to make
scale-up work well we think of them in
these sort of four different domains one
of them is the features of the
innovation what does the thing look like
because some innovations are really easy
to see their results they're very
observable and others are not very
observable you know they're good but
it's really hard to measure it like
management I know it's good but I can't
measure its impact some innovations are
really simple you just take this pill
and some are really hard you know
convince your family it should be okay
for you to be home with the children
when they're infants so that when we
think about the types of innovations
they're going to be some innovations
that diffuse or disseminate much faster
because of their characteristics and
others that just don't so that's one
bucket of information the second bucket
of information is this bottom one which
is the features of the organization's or
people or communities that have to adopt
because haven't you all worked in some
organizations where that county gets it
immediately in that County just is
asleep or you know this hospitals got it
and that one doesn't or this person
understands it and that one doesn't so
there's some features of the actual the
group that's got to adopt it that there
may be certain places that are just
warmer to innovation than others there
people organizations and communities
that are learning organizations they
think about I want to do something new
and there are others that just don't
want it so that's a area the third is
the far left which is really what does
the environment look like is it in as
the environment been created in such a
way that it fosters scale up are the
laws passed the way they should be do
you have the Minister of Finance
Minister of Health do you have the right
financing system and that you know in
your leadership roles you're often in
charge of that external environment
pieces of it and you're in charge of the
innovation and your charge a little bit
of
adopting organization so how do you
align these things of course you're not
really in charge no one ever is but it's
probably within some of your jobs to
really think about how do i create an
external environment that will kind of
suck this innovation forward because
we've created the proclamation or we've
gotten the president to say this is an
important thing etc and then the last
feature of this is the dissemination
strategy what have you used for a
dissemination strategy that will
actually make this more likely to work
or not to disseminate or not disseminate
and I think let's see i said i would go
to 10 15 can it's it's two after ten can
you handle till 10 15 or is that too
late you can handle it okay because i
don't like to torture people passed
their boundaries okay not like David
Berg who kept you late yesterday it's
okay David and I laugh a lot about this
cuz he's always you know boundaries
you're on time for meetings and even you
know and he was late yesterday okay
anyhow the the features of the
innovation from the research point of
view have been found to be these
features and this has been again and
again in many different instances is it
simple or is it perceived to be simple
can you wrap your intervention into
their four things you need to do there
are two things you need to even if it
isn't really simple can you market it so
it's simple so that's one characteristic
compatibility is is it compatible with
the way life is now or can you sell it
that way even if it is really a shift
can you say but this is consistent with
something that is kind of makes people
feel like oh yeah this is compatible
with my values this is what I do the
ability to pilot this is to your point
dr. Asad I think you asked about is it
better to just diffuse an idea or so
have a bit of practice and diffuse the
practice you know the literature would
say it will diffuse faster if you're can
pilot it before any large-scale
investment fourth characteristics can
you see the results and this is to dr.
Gabe Rob and Arielle saying we need the
evidence so can you see result
is it something that you can feel and
see and the last one of course is the
most important one which is is it
perceived by your users to have a
relative advantage compared with the
status quo do and Johnny I think you
brought this up is it really better than
what we have right now and if you have
an idea in your brain that you think is
a good idea but it doesn't meet these
features then it's going to diffuse
slower it is absolutely going to go
slower so I think it's part of sort of
being strategic and think how do I make
this intervention such that it is going
to look like those and what do we need
to do to be sure that is the case does
it make sense for people yeah let me
just see I think given the scope of time
this is just sort of the environmental
pieces that are sort of consistent with
our literature on what drives diffusion
if your environment can look if these
things are consistent with the inner
innovation like the professional norms
they buy it you've got regulatory
requirements that are in sync with what
you want to actually accomplish and you
have financial incentives you know this
is yeah yeah yeah but of course the most
complicated things to get um I think in
terms of the adopting organization there
are many many studies about what kind of
organizations learn better what kind of
organizations actually adopt new ideas
faster I tried to synthesize these into
into something simple that we could
disseminate easily so I'm using the same
tactic of just trying to wrap things in
buckets that we can remember and repeat
but you've all heard this of the
champion inside the organization it's a
large literature on learning
organizations and we tried to put some
readings on that in the back of your
book one by Robert Garvin who's really
are I think the leading expert at least
in the US on identifying learning
organizations there's a nice little tool
there that you can say to you is my
organizational learning organization and
then are there organizational structures
that support adoption I don't know if
people have found certain structures
that really support adoption or not
typically these are there is some kind
of committee structure or governing
structure that is charged with looking
at the environment to understand what is
new out there and we might want to bring
in that's not necessarily the line
operation or the actual people who are
on the units I just want to I think that
this would probably be the best place to
end this piece and to talk a little bit
more about it is the dissemination
strategy so let's say that you've got an
innovation that is simple or you can
sell it as simple compatible you can
pilot it people believe it has a
relative advantage and you have an
external environment that's pretty warm
to bringing this thing on and you have
identified a set of communities that you
think will adopt it still probably not
enough what is the dissemination
strategy what's the way you know if we
were in a pharmaceutical business we
would know our dissemination strategy we
would be we get marketing we'd be ready
to go but we're not in that we're
usually in some kind of medicine or
public health so what's our
dissemination strategy and I think that
you have identified most of the things
on the list although I want to
underscore a couple other ones we
identified in our discussion already
it's got to be based on recommendations
of that come from credible evidence and
i would say that given the discussion
before and I think Jen you brought this
up is people some people think this some
people think that it's really got to be
credible to the people who are going to
adopt it so it doesn't have to be
credible to a huge academic somewhere it
has to be credible to the people who are
changing their minds and sometimes and
we see this all the time in the US even
though we have the NIH and billions of
dollars going to research the single
case study in front of Congress of the
person who's you know got renal failure
that changes whether we're going to pay
for kidney transplant or not not the
billions of randomized trials about
whether kidney transplant is a better
thing to do or not so the
credible evidence is for the people that
means the people who are going to make
the decision to adopt the second part of
a dissemination so get the evidence you
need to convince the people who are
ultimately going to adopt this is sort
of assuming you have faith in it the
second is finding the opinion leaders
and we talked about this before I think
varco you had races and be sure they
adopt at first because even though
they're only maybe ten percent of the
population if they adopt it they bring
sixty percent more and before you know
it you have a majority so getting to
them first and kind of giving up if you
can't get them or wait Angela you said
just be patient maybe it'll be a bit
later the third one I don't think we
actually talked about and I this is
something that i am very wed to is to
give practical tools so people we sit in
our desks and we think great thoughts
and we're writing all the time and and
you're making policy all the time but
what are the practical tools that can be
given to the actual units that are going
to adopt what are the blueprint type
things or the very straightforward easy
to source a ok this is what i do and
that practical tool part i think is the
kind of a critical piece from to avoid
the slippage from the big policy to the
implementation that just have to be
tools and I think that's often something
we don't do that well because we're not
actually at the frontline we don't have
those jobs so how do we create practical
tools but I think that's the leadership
that's tied to you and the leadership
role find the people at the frontline
and engage them enough to create
practical tools and the last the last
part of the dissemination strategy would
be to use professional and social
networks to disseminate the information
you know how do you get into the gossip
chain how do you get into the ones who
know whether that happens to actually be
I don't really mean gossip but what I
mean by that I was supposed to be a joke
here ok what I mean by that is how do
you get into that you know they said it
so i buy it you know how do you get into
the network if you will because that's
really where change happens we all do
that even if we think we're very
rational we actually really do listen to
those people who we just sort of think
know and so how do you use that instead
of trying to be overly rational I think
it's a part of actually using your
emotional intelligence like Peter talked
about is how do you use that part which
is just networking just networking to
get the information across so these
would be my big thoughts about this i'm
going to skip this and just go to the
summary if that's okay and my summary
and then I be happy to have us talk a
little bit more is a good the point of
scale up i guess is just a good idea is
not enough to foster spread just it
could be a great idea does not have legs
in healthcare we don't have the kind of
markets that bring a good idea
automatically forward lots of things can
stop it and the second is scale-up
tactics should be considered as part of
the actual intervention it's not sort of
like you've got an idea and then someone
else will do that actually the idea is
both the idea the innovation and
everything wrapped around it that will
defuse it so that is I think part of the
actual intervention and that's not
unlike Peter salivate either see he is
brilliant because he said Framing you
know sure you can have the technical
idea but you got to frame the
information a certain way for people to
take it same idea and then just last
overall scaling up and sustaining which
we didn't get to that which frankly I'm
just as glad given our conversation the
other day scaling up and sustaining
health initiatives requires joint
commitments from scientists from
management from regulators policymakers
and I would absolutely say in this
really from the front line of the people
who are going to be adopting and
ultimately implementing your
intervention so I think it is 10 it's 10
after 10 if there are a few comments on
this piece of it we probably have a few
minutes for some short comments is there
any thoughts reactions you just want to
leave
it was this helpful at all okay well
okay good well thank you very much for
your time I'm happy to talk about more
of this later